[Musik]
mit 1 wolf und marietta slomka
guten abend nachdem gestern eine
mehrköpfige familie nach deutschland
ausgewiesen wurde
werden heute abend zwei weitere frauen
erwartet die türkei hat sie vor gut drei
stunden ins flugzeug gesetzt
beide sollen aus gefangenenlagern in
syrien entkommen sein und wurden später
in der türkei aufgegriffen
insgesamt ist von 14 personen die rede
die aus der türkei ausgewiesen werden
eine überschaubare zahl aber natürlich
wirft das ein schlaglicht auf die
grundsätzliche frage wie umgehen mit
deutschen staatsbürgern die sich dem s
angeschlossen hatten
bisher hat sich deutschland und dieses
problem weitgehend herumgedrückt das war
den behörden ganz recht dass sich die
kurden in nordsyrien um diese leute
kümmerten
doch man wird nicht darauf zählen können
dass das auch so bleibt und bei manchen
kämpfen auch angehörige für ihre
rückkehr zu sat 1 ab berichtet diese
bilder ihrer neffen und nichten hat die
schwester von yasmina die nicht erkannt
werden will ihr heimlich aus dem
gefangenenlager in nordsyrien geschickt
die haut der kinder soll gefallen sein
von fleischfressenden bakterien
sie alle hätten ständig durch weil ihre
schwester sagt sie wiegen nur 40 kg dass
sie und ihren mann strafen erwarten
davon gehen wir aus aber ich bin der
meinung die bundesregierung muss sie
zurückholen
sie sind drüber gegangen um ein
islamisches leben zu führen
ich habe nie von ihnen gehört dass sie
zum es gehören die deutsche justiz sieht
das anders und wirft jasmin us schwester
mitgliedschaft in einer terroristischen
vereinigung vor genauso wie ihren mann
beide gingen 2013 nach syrien wollen
jetzt unbedingt zurück doch ihre
anwältin beklagt dass es zwar eine
rückhol verpflichtung von deutschen
staatsbürgern gebe die bundesregierung
aber selbst gerichtsurteile ignoriere
und dass es bei kindern ja bei denen ja
lebensgefahr besteht dass die auf jeden
fall zurück geholt werden müssen ja dass
man trotzdem vor gericht ziehen muss und
wochenlang darüber diskutieren muss und
am ende
ein deutsches gericht entscheiden dass
sie eben zurückgeholt werden müssen was
sie ja eigentlich wissen dass sie das
müssen ja das ist schon eines
rechtsstaates nicht würdig die türkei
schiebt seit dieser woche deutsche
angebliche ehemalige es anhänger ab auch
heute wieder zwei frauen in lagern wie
diesem in nordsyrien sind das die
syrisch demokratischen kräfte die das
sagen haben
auch sie hatten die bundesregierung
mehrmals aufgefordert verantwortung für
ihre staatsbürger zu übernehmen ohne
erfolg unter den dutzenden deutschen die
in solchen gefängnissen inhaftiert sind
ist auch mindestens ein sohn von joachim
gerhard dieses bild wurde 2013 ein jahr
vor ihrer ausreise nach syrien gemacht
ob manuel der jüngere noch lebt weiß
joachim gerhard nicht seinen sohn fabian
hat er bei seiner letzten syrien reise
von weitem erkannt durfte aber nicht mit
ihm reden wir sehen durfte damals im
april war für mich schon riesig großer
vor nach fünf jahren zonen zu finden
erlebt und seither versucht er mit hilfe
seiner anwältin fabian so schnell wie
möglich nach deutschland zu holen
doch bislang hat es nicht geklappt und
auch joachim gerhard macht die
bundesregierung verantwortlich und
sitzen deutsche staatsbürger und die
haben für uns nur recht dass du hier vor
gericht kommen nach deutschland wurde
das gericht hier ihre strafe kriegen und
dann wiederum haben die kurden oder die
türken ist recht so sagen nehmt ihr euer
leute zurück und wie gefährlich sind
diese leute thomas mück und sein team
arbeiten gerade mit 36 ehemaligen irs
anhängern zusammen erfolgreich sagt er
doch es gebe unter den möglichen
rückkehrern auch hochgefährliche die
schwere verbrechen verübt hätten
wir gehen davon aus dass sie mit
langjährigen haftstrafen zu tun haben
werden und wir warten die moment ab wo
die menschen wo dieser personenkreis
zweifeln wird dessen was sie getan haben
und wenn sie bereit sind die
verantwortung dafür zu übernehmen können
wir auch mit ihnen arbeiten diese chance
wünscht sich jasmina auch für ihre
schwester sie werde sich vor gericht
verantworten müssen aber in deutschland
sollte das sein
theo koll in berlin um welche dimension
geht es da überhaupt also ursprünglich
sind aus deutschland jahr rund 1000
personen auf die irakischen zwischen
schlachtfelder
nun wenn man es ganz grob einen teil
will dann gilt eine art drittel regelung
ein drittel der ausgereisten ist schon
wieder zurück in deutschland etwas
weniger als ein drittel ist vor ort
verstorben und bei einem weiteren
drittel liegen den behörden keine
erkenntnisse vor aktuell
so hat man uns gesagt geht es um 95
deutsche davon 81 die unter kurdischer
kontrolle sind in nordsyrien und 14 die
unter türkische aufsicht sind was waren
sie dann aus sicherheitskreisen wie das
ein gespräche gefahr von rückkehrern aus
geht nun die sicherheitskreise mit denen
wir sprechen konnten sind zumindest
nicht hochgradig alarmiert die 14 den
türkisch in gewahrsam sind sein so sagen
die sicherheitsexperten beherrschbar
wichtig ist dabei dass die rückführung
organisiert abläuft also dass die
sicherheitsbehörden wissen wer wann wo
ankommt und je nach stand der
vorhandenen informationen erwarten dann
die einreisenden hier überwachungen oder
ermittlungsverfahren oder auch die
inhaftierung das ist sozusagen die
behörden beherrschbar bei den noch in
kurdischer gefangenschaft einsitzenden
ist die derzeitige einschätzung
zumindest dass sie so schnell gar nicht
freikommen werden weil die kurden anders
als man zunächst erwartet hatte
weiterhin die lager und gefängnisse
beaufsichtigen und auch keine kontrolle
kein interesse haben die kontrolle über
diese kämpfer zu verlieren aber macht
sich die deutsche regierung da nicht
auch an langen schlanken fuß aus den
kurven weiter zu überlassen
ja ich glaube das kann man wirklich so
sagen denn bei denen in syrien
inhaftierten hat man ja lange
argumentiert man habe dort keine
diplomatische vertretungen sie hätten
keine pässe und man habe keine
verlässlichen informationen
dabei ist ja bekannt dass deutsche
behörden auch zur befragung selbst vor
ort waren also diese vogel strauß
haltung ist politisch natürlich
verständlich der mit der rücknahme ist
in der bevölkerung hier kein
beliebtheits preis zu gewinnen aber fast
alle experten raten zu einer
kontrollierten und raschen rückholung
denn bei den erwachsenen besteht in den
lagern die gefahr der erneuten
radikalisierung und bei den kindern wird
das problem jetzt abgesehen von dem was
wir eben gesehen haben an
gesundheitlichen problemen umso größer
je älter die kinder werden und alles
sagen die experten ist besser als eine
unkontrollierte und unerkannte rückkehr
dankeschön theo koll nach berlin
menschen die normal leben und dann
plötzlich in einem religiösen oder
ideologischen waren zu solchen
grausamkeiten in der lage sind etwa
einen anderen menschen zu enthaupten
oder dabei frohgemut zuzusehen wie ist
das möglich
von der zivilisation direkt in die
barbarei von der moderne ist mit leute
das kann offenbar sehr schnell gehen
doch man muss ja nur in die deutsche
geschichte blicken um zu sehen wozu
menschen fähig sind und die ganze
gesellschaften in die barbarei kippen
können
in hamburg läuft derzeit einer der wohl
letzten prozesse gegen verbrecher der
ns-zeit der heute 93 jährige angeklagte
war ss wachmann im kz stutthof bei
danzig wozu menschen fähig sind dazu
konnte man während dieser
gerichtsverhandlung auch vieles erfahren
zu welchen grausamkeiten aber auch zu
welch menschlicher größe 18 wand von
seefahrt berichtet moschee peter lot ist
einer der zeitzeugen und auch
nebenkläger im hamburger prozess doch
rache ist seine sache nicht obwohl sein
leben alles andere als leicht und
unbeschwert war nachdem er schon als
baby im konzentrationslager steht auf
dem tod geweiht war und nur durch glück
überlebte ich bekomme so frieden meinen
frieden ich kann dieses kapitel beenden
ich muss es beenden nicht mit mut nicht
mit hass oder dem angeklagten gar den
tod zu wünschen oder foltern 1
roger
und das ist der angeklagte
jahrzehntelang hat bruno die unbehelligt
von der justiz in hamburg gelebt jetzt
wird dem 93-jährigen als ehemaliger kz
wachmann der prozess gemacht die
begegnung der beiden männer im
gerichtssaal sorgte für eine bewegende
szene die für den 76-jährigen moschee
peter lot vermutlich zu einem der
wichtigsten momente in seinem leben
werden kann
ein zeuge hat den angeklagten dann
gefragt ob er ihn umarmen durfte was der
angeklagte auch bereitwillig bejaht hat
und dann ist es zu einer wirklichen und
auch langen umarmung gekommen
auch für die anwälte der überlebenden
hat das hamburger verfahren eine
herausragende bedeutung
es ist natürlich auch ein signal in der
heutigen zeit dass solche prozesse
geführt werden dass täter auch nicht
davon kommen dass sich täter auch mit
den opfern auseinandersetzen
stu dorf bei danzig war von 1939 bis 45
2 eines der weniger bekannten todeslager
in dem aber wie anderswo auch
zehntausende von menschen gefoltert
vergast und erschossen wurden
auch der pole marek du ihn war
schoppitsch überlebte das kz stutthof
als damals so genannter politischer
häftling da waren sie beide 17 und
begegnen sich jetzt wieder 76 jahre
später in einem prozess in hamburg bei
dem es dem überlebenden nicht um rache
schon aber um gerechtigkeit geht egal
was für eine rolle dieser mann in
studios spielte für mich ist er
mitverantwortlich für die verbrechen des
dritten reiches in stoff denn er hat
einen direkten oder indirekten einfluss
auf die geschehnisse im lager genommen
für masche pilot verbindet sich mit der
begegnung vor dem hamburger gericht eine
große genugtuung
ich wollte mich befreien und will auch
dass er sich befreit fühlen kann wie er
damit klarkommt wir haben gerichte dafür
dass gerechtigkeit gefunden wird konnte
ich habe meine gerechtigkeit bekommen an
dem ich letztlich jemanden aus stoff
getroffen habe und meint damit den
ehemaligen ss angehörigen bruno die der
sich noch bis zum februar nächsten
jahres für beihilfe zum mord in 5230
fällen vor dem hamburger landgericht
verantworten muss
jetzt blicken wir in die usa in
washington gehen die anhörungen zum
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen donald
trump in die nächste runde
heute trat die ehemalige
us-botschafterin in der ukraine als
zeugin auf marie jovanovic ist eine
karriere diplomatin mit interessanter
biografie ihre eltern waren in den 50er
jahren aus der statistischen sowjetunion
geflüchtet sie wuchs in connecticut auf
studierte unter anderem an der
eliteuniversität princeton und ging
später in den diplomatischen dienst für
den sie über 30 jahre arbeitete auf
verschiedenen posten im in und ausland
vor diesem hintergrund kann man sich
vorstellen was ist für die
top-diplomaten bedeutete als sie von der
tramp regierung von ihrem posten in der
ukraine vorzeitig abberufen sprich
gefeuert wurde und was ist für sie
bedeutet dass präsident trump sie heute
per twitter öffentlich beleidigte und
ihre kompetenz in zweifel zog aus
washington motives es wäre ein ganz
normaler tag in shorts kevin wender
nicht was ganz besonderes im fernsehen
wie vor den augen der öffentlichkeit
nicht sich der amerikanische präsident
in eine zeugenbefragung 1
aber beginnen wir von vorne mario
vidovic weiß dass sie sich dass männer
als schuldig macht wenn sie den kongress
belügt im mai 2009 10 hatte donald trump
die us botschafterin in der ukraine
vorzeitig abberufen
sie sei wohl ein hindernis gewesen für
die neben außenpolitik von trumps
persönlichem anwalt rudy giuliani
mit grundlosen unterstellungen sorgten
sie dafür dass der präsident sich
absetzte obwohl das außenministerium
wusste dass die anschuldigungen falsch
waren und die quellen obskur das sollte
jeden in diesem raum so unruhigen
botschafter sind das symbol der
vereinigten staaten im auslassen
kurz danach platzt dann die anhörung
eine meldung donald trump beschimpft
marie jovanovic per twitter noch während
sie aus sagt wo immer sie hingegen sei
es schlecht ausgegangen die zeugin ringt
um worte
ich weiß nicht was der präsident damit
bezweckt aber es wirkt einschüchtern
botschafterin einige von uns nehmen die
einschüchterung von zeugen sehr sehr
ernst was da gerade passiert ist gilt
nach amerikanischem recht als
zeugenbeeinflussung und ist strafbar
in chost herren sind die zuschauer darf
wie der präsident eine top diplomat ihn
runter macht man merkte dass sie sich
von trump eingeschüchtert fühlte
hoffentlich beeinflusst das nicht ihre
aussage in einer live zeugen beeinflusst
wer der räder nicht erschreckt und
besorgt die demokraten werden das wohl
zu einem eigenen anklagepunkt machen
neben ribery bestechung nach der
verfassung ein klarer grund für
amtsenthebung weiß der präsident selbst
zugibt und perfekt nennt war genau das
gegenteil bestechung donald trump wird
sich vor anhängern in lousiana gestern
beleidigte er die zeugen und seine
demokratischen widersacher
[Applaus]
die absolut verrückten wahnsinnigen die
demokratische radikale linke und ihre
medienpartner dahinten sie pushen einen
patch mit hexenjagd obwohl ich nichts
falsch gemacht haben wie sehr die
anhörungen polarisieren zeigt eine
partei von den trumps die stadt die
zeugin weiter zu befragen den
ausschussvorsitzenden angreift weil er
einen whistleblower nicht als zeugen
aufrufen will
das sei amtsmissbrauch strumps so der
demokrat dem whistleblower für verrat
deshalb müsse man ihn schützen am ende
dieses zweite anhörung stars hat man den
eindruck dass alle zeugen schutz
bedürfen wenn sie berichten wie es war
und jetzt die nachrichten vom 12 der
bundestag hat mit den stimmen der
koalitionsfraktionen wesentliche teile
des klimaschutz paketes beschlossen
vorgesehen sind verschiedene maßnahmen
um den co2 ausstoß zu reduzieren ein
zentrales element ist ein co2 preis für
sprit heizöl oder gas
im gegenzug soll es für die verbraucher
entlastungen geben haus dämmungen oder
der austausch von ölheizungen sollen
gefördert und die pendlerpauschale soll
erhöht werden
zum klimaschutz gehört auch die
energiewende und dazu wiederum die
windkraft hier sind jetzt die geplanten
abstandsregeln für windräder heftig
umstritten
die bundesregierung und die
koalitionsspitzen hatten sich darauf
verständigt dass künftig mindestens 1000
meter abstand zahlen müssen
zwischen windrädern und wohnsiedlungen
dagegen haben sich jetzt die
umweltminister der länder ausgesprochen
der mindestabstand sei das falsche
signal so werde der ausbau der windkraft
verhindert mehr geld für den klimaschutz
ist auch im bundeshaushalt für das
kommende jahr vorgesehen
der etat ist bei einer marathon sitzung
des zuständigen ausschusses jetzt
festgezurrt worden
insgesamt sind ausgaben von rund 362
milliarden euro geplant rund 5,5
milliarden euro mehr als in diesem jahr
neue schulden sollen
gemacht werden in bielefeld hat am
nachmittag der parteitag der grünen
begonnen
ihr vorsitzender harbeck gab das ziel
aus die zeit nach der ära merkel
maßgeblich mitzubestimmen
in einer rede vor etwa 800 delegierten
sagte er die grünen brauchten pläne die
den horizont wieder aufmachten und
herausführten aus dem klein klein
hauptthemen des parteitags sind
klimaschutz wirtschaft und
wohnungspolitik morgen steht die
doppelspitze der burg & harbeck zur
wiederwahl
bei den protesten in hongkong sind zwei
deutsche festgenommen worden
dabei soll es sich um austausch
studenten handeln das deutsche
generalkonsulat habe sich eingeschaltet
so das auswärtige amt für diplomatische
spannungen zwischen großbritannien und
china sorgt derweil ein angriff auf
hongkongs justizministerium in london
wurde sie von demonstranten bedrängt und
stürzte zu boden
china verurteilte den angriff und
beschwerte sich bei der britischen
regierung kuba havanna
da kommen natürlich schnell lauter
klischeebilder die bunten kolonial
fassaden über allem weht die musik des
buena vista social clubs und ein hauch
von che guevara
diese melange macht gruber ja auch zu
einem reizvollen urlaubsziel zwischen
karibik flair und retro trip die
politische unterdrückung die
menschenrechtsverletzungen die in kuba
nach wie vor stattfinden werden das
schnell ausgeblendet aber das gilt ja
für viele andere reiseziele dieser welt
natürlich genauso
wirklich frei war kuba noch erst kam die
spanischen kolonialherren dann diverse
diktatoren und schließlich die
kommunistischen revolutionäre morgen
feiert havanna seien 500 jähriges
bestehen bei allem stolz vielen kubanern
ist in diesen zeiten nicht zum jubeln
zumute
ines trams berichtet traditionelle
oldtimer vor dem restaurant von raúl
kuba so mögen ist die touristen
kubanisch auch dass raúl nicht alles von
der karte servieren kann weil ihm die
zutaten fehlen immer schon musste er in
der mangelwirtschaft kubas improvisieren
derzeit fehlt es jedoch an den
undankbarsten dingen wie kann es sein
dass es in kuba keinen zucker gibt dann
muss halt honig oder rot zucker her
letzte woche brachte mir eine freundin
zucker weil ich auf facebook gepostet
hatte dass ich nur noch einen kleinen
rest hatte
havanna feiert geburtstag den 500 doch
havanna ja ganz kuba steckt in einer
krise
jahrzehntelange misswirtschaft verstärkt
durch ein verschärftes us embargo und
die krise des verbündeten venezuela die
tankstellen wegen benzinmangels
geschlossen
es fehlt an seife da an papier für die
zeitung sie ist nur noch halb so dick
für die menschen wird der kampf um dinge
des täglichen bedarfs aufwendiger hier
im hinterhof wohnen 28 parteien
keiner hat genug fand er wäscht
gebrauchte eisbecher die er dann wieder
verkauft ein zubrot zu seinem
staatlichen job alles was wir brauchen
müssen wir uns mühselig zusammensuchen
sonst stirbst du auch seine ehefrau
beatrice klagt sie leben ohne fließend
wasser
die kanalisation funktioniert nicht
politiker und behörden aber täten nichts
du machst alles um die dinge
einigermaßen herzurichten irgendwie zu
überleben
was glaubst du warum alle das land
verlassen weil es hier so nicht
weitergeht
[Applaus]
bauer lazzaro und sein sohn müssen wie
so viele bauern den traktor stehen
lassen und zurück zum ochsengespann vor
den toren havanna es auf dem land
verschärft der mangel an benzin die
versorgungskrise 80 prozent seiner
lebensmittel muss kuba bereits
importieren nun könnte es mehr werden
unsere produktion ist schon
zurückgegangen wegen des benzinmangels
wir bauen weniger an
es gibt weniger boden es wäre gut wenn
der staat sich mehr um uns bauern
kümmern würde
wir sind schließlich die das volk
versorgen
eine krise nicht nur hausgemacht leer
die plätze in havanna die früher voll
waren mit touristen präsident trump
schränkt den us tourismus deutlich ein
er will kuba wirtschaftlich
strangulieren setzt da an wo es wehtut
wir sind trotz allem fröhlich wir
wachsen mit den schwierigkeiten typisch
kubanisch restaurantchef raúl
verabschiedet seine amerikanischen gäste
bald dürfen solche reisegruppen aus den
usa nicht mehr kommen kuba blickt einmal
wieder in eine ungewisse zukunft
und jetzt nochmal eins hat meldungen aus
der deutschen wirtschaft
der volkswagen konzern hat die
investitionsplanung für die nächsten
fünf jahre festgelegt mit milliarden für
zukunftsthemen bei der reha
wie und wo werden diese milliarden
investiert das geld solle vorwiegend in
die e autoflotte fließen in
digitalisierung in die forschung für
autonomes fahren ja und außerdem sollen
vw fabriken im in und ausland auf die
herstellung von batteriebetriebenen
autos getrimmt werden
die zeichen stehen bei volkswagen also
voll auf e mobilität in den nächsten
zehn jahren will der vw konzern bis zu
75 reine e modelle auf den markt bringen
denn anfang dabei macht die kürzlich
eröffnete vw fabrik in zwickau hier wird
der erste rein elektrische id3
hergestellt der volkswagen sattelt
nochmal kräftig drauf der plan für die
kommenden fünf jahre sieht gigantische
investitionen vor 60 milliarden euro
damit fließen fast die hälfte der
gesamten vw investitionen in das auto
von morgen 33 milliarden euro allein ins
e-auto das geld für die investitionen
will vw aus gewinnen und sparprogrammen
beziehen das könnte auch bedeuten dass
weiterhin arbeitsplätze verloren gehen
denn die herstellung von e autos
benötigt weniger arbeitsschritte als
herkömmliche verbrenner anders als
andere autohersteller konzentriert sich
vw vorwiegend auf die batterietechnik ob
die sich beim kunden durchsetzt kann
heute niemand sagen klar ist nur die
strategie kostet milliarden
vw geht also eine riskante wette ein
valerie haller vielen dank in einem so
genannten raser-prozess in stuttgart hat
das landgericht den fahrer zu fünf
jahren haft verurteilt weil er den tod
von zwei menschen verursacht hat der
richter griffen bei ihrem urteil auf
einen rechten neues gesetz zurück das
seit september 2017 gilt
er stellt nicht nur autorennen sondern
auch grob verkehrswidriges fahren mit
höchstgeschwindigkeit unter strafe
der 21 jährige war im märz mit einem
gemieteten sportwagen auf ein stehendes
auto geprallt in dem ein junges paar
starb ob gegen das urteil revision
eingelegt wird ist noch nicht bekannt
am schlusstag der fahrer wm der
leichtathleten in dubai hat es heute
zwei weitere medaillen für das deutsche
team gegeben
über 400 meter gewann johannes flores
seine zweite goldmedaille teamkollege
leon schäfer holte über 100 meter silber
leon schäfer verfolgt gleich nach seinem
finale auf das 400 meter rennen von
teamkollege johannes claas der
beidseitig unterschenkelamputierte 24
jährige läuft ein einsames rennen gegen
die uhr
dass er in neuer weltrekordzeit von 45
78 sekunden souverän gewinnt erst als
ich über die ziellinie bin und dann auch
eine fünf wochen kamera gestanden ist
was irgendwie auch ein gesagt habe ich
will diese fünf vorm komma das war ein
gigantisches gefühl auch der
oberschenkel amputierte leon schäfer hat
kurz zuvor sein zweites wm gold vor
augen wird aber noch vor der ziellinie
vom ländern wagner abgefangen
ich bin zufrieden war eine sehr gute wm
waren super stimmung her ich bin an sich
habe an sich hat wie kann das ganze
deutsche team sein mit noch einmal
silber und gold am schlusstag 291.000
mitglieder hat der fc bayern mehr als
jeder andere sportverein ein mitglied
überragt sie natürlich alle uli hoeneß
fast 50 jahre lang hat er die geschicke
dieses vereins entscheidend mitbestimmt
als spieler als manager und schließlich
als präsident
trainer und spieler kamen und gingen
darunter sogar kaiser und titan
doch er stand die ganze zeit über ganz
vorne
selbst als er vorübergehend aus dem
sichtfeld verschwinden musste war nie
wirklich weg
heute wurde hoeneß als präsident
verabschiedet und so wurde die
jahreshauptversammlung nicht zum ersten
mal zu uli hoeneß festspielen stefan
beer und claudia neumann waren da in
münchen dabei der präsident ist bewegt
als in die mitglieder feiern auch franck
ribéry und arjen robben sind extra
gekommen ist ja auch ein einschnitt in
der geschichte dieses fußballclubs mit
haut und haaren fc bayern immer schon
kaum jemand hat einen sportverein so
geprägt wie uli hoeneß die bayern und
umgekehrt
ich habe dem fc bayern alles was ich
heute habe zu verdanken
und deshalb hat mich das immer getrieben
dem fc bayern das zurückzugeben was er
mir 20 oder jetzt 30 jahre lang gegeben
hat inzwischen sind es fast 50 jahre
seit 18 jähriger abiturient ohne geld
beim club anheuert schon als spieler ist
er für die attacke zuständig wird
weltmeister 74 eine verletzung bereitet
den übergang zum manager vor mit 27
einen job den er dann neu erfindet der
verein ist verschuldet aber nicht mehr
lange
als einziger überlebender beim absturz
eines kleinflugzeugs in hannover 1982
entgeht er dem tod
die lebensaufgabe bleibt die bayern groß
machen das prinzip attacke behält dabei
laut und deutlich und manchmal auch
ziemlich von oben herab dass wir uns
dafür stellt
und dann kannst du dir deine dinge
hinter die ohren schmieren wir werden
den schiedsrichter in zukunft ablehnen
und ich kann mir kaum vorstellen dass er
jemals wieder ein spiel von beiden mit
charakter starken spielern eigenwillig
wie er macht er den verein zur welt
marke schafft grundlage für
trainerkarrieren deutsche
meisterschaften pokalsiege und endlich
den gewinn der champions league 2001
mit dem bau des eigenen stadions
entsteht ein bayerisches statussymbol
nicht von ungefähr gestaltet wie ein
roter diamant nach 30 jahren als manager
wird er zum präsidenten bekommt preise
auch für sein soziales engagement und
entpuppt sich als millionenschwerer
börsenzocker mit suchtpotenzial wegen
steuerhinterziehung in millionenhöhe
wird er 2014 zu dreieinhalb jahren
freiheitsstrafe verurteilt
die hälfte davon verbringt er im
gefängnis doch sein ende als
galionsfigur ist das nicht vor drei
jahren das comeback an der vereinsspitze
er ist einfach zu beliebt es geht nicht
ohne ihn er hat natürlich im deutschen
fussball schon zog geprägt wie kaum ein
anderer
nun also das ende einer ära am abend in
münchen der abschied
es war eine wunderschöne zeit ich sage
ihnen das war's ich habe fertig danke
die macht beim fc bayern gibt er ab aber
er bleibt in der nähe
da kann man sicher sein jetzt kommt noch
das wetter und dann die heute show und
dann aspekte und dann um 23 50 heute
plus auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter ungewöhnliche mehr
an da vollzieht der jetstream derzeit
sehen ist es reicht weit in den süden
und dann wieder in den norden
das kann mal kurz passieren dann ist es
normal aber wenn sie über längere zeit
über anderthalb wochen geht es eben
nicht mehr normal und diese art von
wetterlagen die nehmen immer weiter zu
in den letzten jahren und sie sehen hier
es reicht einmal bis nach grönland
außerhalb des bildes wieder runter bis
nach nordafrika und wieder nach
skandinavien und was hat das zur folge
dass sehen wir hier ein kleines tief das
wandert von süd nach nord anstatt von
west nach ost und bringt uns etwas regen
aber in der alpenregion
da wird es kräftig regnen und schneien
heute und in den nächsten tagen da
bildet sich schon wieder ein neues
sturmtief schauen wir auf die nacht
unter sehen wir das tief zieht ja nach
norden und löst diesen regen jahr aus
und dabei sinken die temperaturen im
osten auf sieben bis acht grad hier
kommt etwas mildere luft an sonst sind
es im westen minus drei grad hier so
frostig kalt morgen ist es im süden
schon etwas ruhiger nach norden hin ist
das tief aber noch aktiv und hier regnet
es kräftig dazu gibt es kräftigen wind
sie sehen es hier an den dickeren fallen
die temperaturen dazu im osten sind auch
etwas höher bei 12 grad im süden sind es
vier grad die nächsten tage am sonntag
geht s recht durchwachsen weiter 14 grad
da noch im osten ja auch die neue woche
wird ebenfalls recht wechselhaft werden
und es wird vor allem etwas kühler
ein schöner abend